Hello Everybody My name is Markiplier and welcome back to
mmwWest of Loathing is what it's actually called and not something else I was gonna say and I don't know what that is
But either way
We Got done with the bureaucratic nightmare that's there, but we still don't
Have a Logging Permit for it, because we need to wait TWO DAYS for that.
But I don't have two days to wait!
i need to go and Get This train done did but before i do that i gotta find me a
Girder
My horn Swabia agger Stern Teddy Bear or something of the like and i remember the the skeleton that i
Ran Into in This hill Over here and also That Lady Maybe you have something in there i don't know idea but i didn't tell?
This skellington Number One That he was Halogen or Number two
That Other Cultists are Dead from another Skeleton Hello Who are you wait i already know this
but i
took care of Them Already i don't you remember this
It's okay i took care of them oh Great Whoo That's a Load off my Mind
Let me tell you Here you can Have This Worry stone i don't need it now
This Rock has had a hole rubbed in it by Incessant Whirring
Fidgeting With It Will Stop You from Looking so anxious all The time This goes in your offhand
Aha an old West
Fidget Spinner Huh Very nice Got some good moxie on that one but i don't know if i want to replace My
Sweet-smelling Flowers Actually i absolutely want to do that I don't know i've had that Still there i'm gonna put my Worry Stones that i
Don't always Be spinning my fidgety all The Way Wherever i'm going But there's Got to be something else Here That
I'm missing There's Still the Thing in the lost dutch Oven month The circus
What better Place to find a teddy Bear
Not a circus
can i go in the Goddamn tent Now
What
Have i not done this did i not do this i'd like to see i'd like to run away with you
I'd like to see it then please have i not oh That's right?
Okay i get i remember i forgot about it that uh that i didn't i didn't
Redo The Circus spit on My playthrough so i'll be right back
oh
Frabjous day Callooh Callay oh My gosh i've Got a large Brush owl
yeah yeah i
Got That okay so what i did Was i actually did i already Got The Tickets Aws is doing all These cuz my stats are
So high by now so i'm Just gonna do this I'M gonna What surprise
Do literally attitude It a Shoot like a Jaguar
That's super neat okay but Now i've Got
Two large Plushies and i don't Need One of them and i can Carry My cat With me can i get a little Fluffy one
What is this Goddamn Mainstage gonna be open
Show Until Later oh my god of course it's Later When the hell does That Happen it doesn't nothing
This is nothing Barnaby Bob Is a Sham and a Liar But Now i have Everything i need for
Frisco
for Frisco
Defend Myself I don't Know What's happening but i'll defend Myself
How about this bang bang bang oh well that did not Work out for you either Way i got an a+
Aminal so now i can take My Plushed a Module on to this trade
Walk Over The Way over dere
Here go through Here back Up here go over Yonder Way As i
Explain Everything That I'm Doing in
Excruciating detail
you Know like a Let's Player Wood and
Okay these People Here got you on Board you're on Board you and Russell are on Board Russell Crowe by the Way
Russell The Crowe
Russell Crowe Anyway alright Hello
How about this plush al wolf well She's Great she takes the owl and Gives It a Big hug
okay Mister Say The Word and we'll show That Jerk What for alright it's
We tie for This we're gonna confront You norton I'm
Uninstalling Oh i only Needed three ah
You Pound on the door to the locomotive or engine car cab or Whatever open up norton no?
All right Then i'm coming in oh yeah you and What Army Tough guy
me in this
Army You and the passengers Break down the Door Very impressively though It would have Been even Better if you had some torches in those
Old-Fashioned Rakes Norton Has Backed Up into the
Corner of The engineer's compartment Next to the engineer who looks over his Shoulder at You and shrugs
So called Emperor Norton You're Under arrest for the crime of being a Total Ass That's not illegal it is When i'm in town
Pachow Put chow chow Put. Ciao cacao, oh?
Where there so is it that i shot Him up real Good like
Right Actually If You could Turn Around and Head back to frisco at the Next station That'd Be Great oh wait it is
Everyone Grabbed Him except You Mr
Engineer i can See we're Busy driving the train right Turn back
To frisco no problem Ow Let Go this isn't over you Haven't Heard The last of me tell it to the Judge
Norton The Prison
Ha got Him got Him good got Him good we made it oh Fan twit what do you Say about popping okay
You did it thanks Boss
No problem We Got the track Laid right Up to the station now i know this wasn't My Voice before but you can ignore That
The First Half Across Territory Railroad Thanks to the manifest destiny
D destiny our Railroad cou Company Company and
principaling You You did a Real Good Job mum fleur Thumper Dink Aw Shucks don't Mention It and call me Boss
Please
You Really Should okay oh? Oh?
My Goodness oh My
Goodness This Is a One-Way train Why they build a One-Way train can't They Just pick it up and Turn It Around and then to
Be a
Two-Way train alright Whatever i guess It can Only Go Forward so looks like Somebody on That train Got the job as a projectionist
Would You like to watch This movie it'S free because movies Have only Recently Been invented Nobody's figured Out that you they can charge?
for them yet no
Doing This Will Not Change anything about the World of Your character When the cutscene is over you'll still be right here and you can
Keep Playing If You Want Show me the final cutscene
That's the
Excuse you
well i'll be a New face i'm Clooney include
Salute see Make Yourself at home
Thanks I'm mum fleur fun ting new to town
Up in helping manifest Destiny Get The rail tracks Lady It Was a Tough Job but We Finally Got Here
Sounds Like You could use a Drink Clean sea i sure could What have you got oh?
I'll take This olive gin cone sure whatever that means all right Got that Also oh?
Boy another Spittoon Let's Go What's with the
Get Up this is the last Petunia in the game and i'm not gonna try and convince you to not be the most
disgusting person on earth anymore Let's Go let's do this
What if i back away slowly
Slowly ah Boring alright Yeah search that Filthy Splatoon
you Kneel Down on the floor and Throw Your Arms Around the Spittoon
Giving The Greasy Brass Bucket a Great Big hug how about
Would You like to Kiss it you know it baby
You Pucker Up and give this Batoon a Great big Kiss right on the rim is there time
I'll leave it up to you but even without it it tastes like a Burning a horse i love it i know
And if It were legal in this country that Spittoon and have a Beautiful Romantic?
Night With it but Unfortunately you're going to have to settle for Wearing It As a
yes
Drenching Yourself and Hot Brown tobacco spit It washes down over your face in here like a
Sewage Waterfall
Soaking Your Clothes running Down your collar and
Slithering Into Your Underwear and Filling Your Boots i can't even force Myself to describe it in any more detail Than That
You are the World's most foul list Human Being
Congratulations
This Is a Spittoon That Which is to say It's a Spittoon
That you have Turned upside down and Placed on top of your Head oh?
i wish i was a Bean slinger i
Really Wish oh, oh?
look i wish It Said spit Upside down on it
I'm gonna put a Snakeskin on it do i have Any more Rainbow Snake Skins
Sic python oh this skin Was until Very Recently stretched taut Around some giant Pulsating
Stomach Muscles it'S gross to think about and to
look at but i get 30 HP for it That's Pretty dang Good
Oh apply to my hat blam you stretched the python Skin Around your hat your hat?
Immediately Gets more Muscular and Baby, oh
My Spit
The veins are pumping Sweet tobacco Spit Around It for Circulation ah
That's
Terrible oh hello
What's all This then it's a real frisco Fracas all Right sure
We Got The Jump on him this time Why do i want to kill these Guys i
Don't know if i do but here i go i guess bang bang bang
Well They're Dead Now you emerge from the brawl relatively Unscathed
Alright Goodbye Then i don't Feel like Murdering anybody Else
Sorry no darts management Known as Dirt oh my god it drips of
Course It drips it'S pulsating with veins it's Got a Drip it's a Flyer of some sorry i can't Read It seems Oddly
Smudged With Water damage or What i can Only assume is water damage you Got a Comedy Flyer
This is something you found on the ground in frisco Which means that in the absolute best case scenario it's garbage
Well time to look at that Garbage
Read It Read the garbage It turns Out to be a flyer for a Comedy
Shack Up north of frisco You Jot Down the Location on your map and Throw the flyer away you discover a New map Location
roscoe's Comedy Shack
okay alright Then Hello hello ding dong Bing bong it's Just Nearly Identical Houses as far as the eye can see in that Direction
oh
But Gluten Sees
It can't be over i gotta go to the comedy Shack i'll see the it said i could Play The game
After This Final Cutscene but i'll Get that at The end of the episode i want to see What's up with wasco is comedy Shack
Guys with a name Like Wasco you
can't be wong F
Alright oh watering Sally i Would Wondering Where you were wandering a Hello
Hey Gary oh?
Hey ha oh i think this is we're living a Crazy Squirrel man's a What Now Crazy squirrel man's you see
You discovered a New Map Location Holloway's Hideout
Ok alright What do you think we Should do Next
Wow the day you Saving It Shucks i couldn't have done it Without you gary come on Let's Go to the Final gutsy
Hoping Having a Happy ending Gary Loves Happy ending oh?
The zoo dice are what do you got i don't care give me that i need that fungicide well if i was?
Hmm i'm gonna buy that Because There's a Possibility it's the Possibility
All Right Anyway so there's a Possibility
That You remember That Shack in that Thing with i'm dripping sorry Sally You've Seen me in better Days but
Uh you know today is not that day but There Was a Shack that had all the goblins That were Exploding in it
your booze
Senses Dingles You Spurt in flirt Towards the source of the disturbance in the liquor sphere and find a Little Still Hidden in the pines
You discover Moonshine Still i'm gonna go to moscow Comedy Shack Where Comedy can't go wrong
Hey Gary What are gobbling Jokes like do you Know any Good ones oh?
Knowing Very Funny Joke a Goblin to entering
Human bar and Human Bartender to Saying hello
we do not serve a Goblin and the Goblin Saying of Course not You are full of Juice is Very
Funny pun Probably Not Translating Very Well not so much no not at all
Bosco's Comedy Shack Funny ha ha yuk yuK Joke Jokes oh My
All Right Nice hat
I'm Glad we Could Meet on this such a
prestigious day oh
Howdy Howdy Howdy
Whoa ah skosh afters a name and comedies again i'd like to think this guy has my voice you know the voice of someone who
Thinks he's funnier Than he Actually is we're here for a Real thigh slapping Good time it'S me markiplier ah
All Right Hit me
Yeah and Over the meat and wasco Clears his Throat
Ok, so a Skeleton Walks into a bar and the bartender Says Wait it's a horse not a Skeleton Sorry
AnyWay After The Bartender Asked the horse
Hey Why is your face so long buddy
Seriously Wasco Takes about
wanna Hear another Word i sure do
Already guy Walks into a bar and the bartender Says Sorry we don't serve goblins Here oh yeah i forgot to mention the guy's goblin?
AnyWay I'm the end whoa boy?
Okay Here's a Good one take My Wife please Please That's it
Hit me Anyway i Just flew in from canadia Which is Weird right Because People can't Fly Except for in Balloons or Gliders i guess
we don't have Actual Airplanes for at Least another couple of Decades Anyway
okay
Hit me
Guy Walks into a bar he asks for a beer and a Mop and bartender Says What's the mop for
Guy replies Because I'm a Skeleton oh?
Come on wasco Wasco Your Real Bad It is
Not your Bad it the stuff you do Dumb Things probably i shoot
People want to test That Theory come on Let me tell you another one
All Right Hit me
Nope don't like Dowan your Z aren't good at Comedy shut Up i'm great at Jokes no you aren't
What about my your Timing is terrible Timing
I'm telling You Sincerely you Should quit
Well That's That's Pretty Direct but i gotta be honest Man Alright alright fine i admit it can't tell Jokes Worth a Darn
and My name is not wasco its markiplier What else Am i gonna do
You're Pretty Decent Banjo Player The Jewel and dirt Water could use a Banjo oh That Sounds Pretty Good can't be much worse okay bye
did i do a Celebratory Flip
can i go in the Shack
Alright Then well he's Now there Now and That's Great
I'm gonna go to the moonshine still and see What That's about i'm gonna Defend Myself apparently Shaw bang bang bang alright You're Dead now
Things Seem a Lot Easier Now that i can shoot Things Real hard also i haven't taken care of the Necromancer?
This is your moonshine under this Spout i
Got a German Chain
Alright Then Why did i get a Jar moonshine i
Think i stole This
you Drink The moonshine then how old with The empty jar
That moonshine You Drank represents everything That's Bad about Alcohol and Equal measure it's a Good Thing you're drunk or you might be moved to
Take Up temperance oh, whoo oh?
whoo whoo whoo
All right Well did That That's great ah
Yes a Still fer to stealin
Distilling Yeah Good Eye Although It'S a little more calm okay then Looking at One my own Class also differing from cactus still
Alright Well i used it so i guess i'm done requires me
Requires boon yes
Bits of Mood
What Does that Mean
Holloway do you know oh?
Mining or Maybe First-aid Supplies alright Whatever Whoa hey
That's a Lot of Stuff i got a cage
Canary It's hard to be scared of anything with This Little guy always chirping a cheerful tune oh?
oh
That's Nice a Medical gun
Do You don't think about it too much a pistol is Just a more effective sir
I'm not gonna think about that. Too much Because it Makes sense
Immediately I don't even Need to think about It this Blood Splatter is disturbingly Squirrel Shit
Your partner yes Here being a Crazy Squirrel Man's it Doesn't
Seem to be a Lot of Squirrels Around Here he is a Squirrel shop you mean he sells squirrels What for no selling to squirrels
Okay hello
This Barrel Used to have Pickles in It now it's Just Nasty old Pickle Juice okay
Howdy Names Holloway Hab Holloway King of The Squirrels Sorry for the chittering i ain't Seen another person in a long Time
It's not surprising This Place is Pretty Secluded What do you do out Here?
Mostly I sell Pine cones to squirrels he frowns well i used to huh all right
you choose on something I had stored Away in one of His cheeks
What Happened to the squirrels but One day They were here next there are Bloodstains
I had the creepiest dream That night i Dreamt a Little girl with a Big empty White eyes
Jumped in Through My Bedroom window and Asked me if i wanted to have Tea Party
Let'S talk about something Else All The Way i found this Silver Pin
Dang it
oh i had a
I'll sell but not to see that Again i locked It up with the Keys inside on purpose too many Bad memories
Appreciate Them Intention That's Rokon to you but Go ahead and Keep It is there something
To do with Why you live all the Way Out here with the squirrels i Just don't feel comfortable in regular society no more
Is it something to do with This old Pickaxe i think he's a
Wear Squirrel I'm Pretty Sure This guy Is a Wear squirrel you know like a Werewolf but a Wear squirrel
I'm a cod no i didn't do nothing he starts chattering Wildly and squirrel Whoa whoa whoa easy there calm Down man?
putting It Away Never Mind he grabbed the holloway grabs a Paper Bag from Under the counter and
Hyperventilates Into It for a Bit eventually he calms down though he still is Kind of a Wild look in his eye
So welcome to my Shop Kinda freak
Let me see what you're selling it so i'm pretty sure
I'm gonna buy one of These because i haven't Seen One of These anywhere it's a Pawn bow tie
You Would never Wear This but Maybe You'll find a Child That Needs Help getting Break for a Funeral
Heavily Sounds Like alright fine i'll buy It jar Peanut Butter can i rub it on the face
Can I Rub The Peanut Butter on the face you know rubble Peanut Butter on my face
Can I Rub The Peanut Butter on my face and call Myself the King of The squirrels gonna do That
I'm gonna do That
by These
Fag You
AnyWay Won't pry Further so there's something about holloway here in that Silver pin maybe You Was in that mauve?
Madness Mind you know the lost dutch Oven mine and That's What That's all about
But i think i'm getting close to the end of this episode and
I Just want to see what this guy can do with This this Jewelry have a look oh? Ah?
I need to get some meat i need to sell some stuff before
I'm Able to do that But there wasn't a shop in frisco maybe There was maybe it's shelf Stuff at Any Shop and
I don't know
I'll be right back okay i'm back Now i have meat you want some meat i've Got Plenty of meat Here's a strange Silvery Crystal
you Got a Silicon Ring
Cannot Be Feeling This Ring Is a waste of Whatever that Silver Crystal Was but on the other hand it Is a Very Nice Ring
How about the unbreakable Ruby Master Gerald Takes Your Unbreakable Ruby Cuts and Polishes It and Sets a fine Ring
Unbreakable Ruby Ring This circle Shall Remain Unbroken Actually The circle is the Weak part it's the Gem that won't break
well Great Good for me
Okay there's no point to any of That okay so i a back to frisco it is so i'm gonna see this Final cutscene
Right After i hornswoggle this Whatever i got a Muck Clogged
Blunderbuss
Wait okay wow you Haven't Been taking Very Good care of That gun What were you Half Buried on the ocean floor for like 40?
Years Yes oh
Really huh well Anyway That's prob That Thing's probably Just gonna Explode if you Try to fire it let me have a look i can
Probably tune It up for you the Skeleton Hands Over his gun and you Inspect It Carefully and then use it to blow his skull
Clean off okay no My mistake it's a Bit Mucky but it's basically fine
That's a Nice gun
Amok Clogged Blood Nervous i'd like to think that the muck Adds a Little Extra
moxie Onto It is that Better Than my Befoul pistol
Well i mean i gotta admit going from a Beef fowl do a Muck Clogged you know
The Spittoon hat Does abide such
Transgressions so i think that we can All forgive each Other As i
It'll muck all the Way back to the movie theater so here we Go
Some folks Say Endings don't matter
But Other Folks They like to know how things Turn Out the consequences of Their actions like
With The trains running Again Frisco Thrived People came from all Over to seek their Fortunes but thanks to you they didn't
Have to do it While on fire because some cow attacked Their Wagon oh?
press Any Key to continue
look at All These People That are
Moderately Not Happy but You Know They're okay They're living live on the wood that Guy's Asleep but Whatever ah?
look at All These
Identical Houses That They Wouldn't Let me see but i'm Kind of curious to see What's at the end of The row iF
if anything
All right These Other People That were in the game oh?
You're gonna call me boss
okay Bye Then all right look at All These People look at all Their hats look at That Drugged-out guy oh
That's so Nice
This is a Good
with The Railroad completed in Norton Out stood Smee Found Himself out of a Job but with an
Opportunity after Being Elected Mayor he Managed the Growth and infrastructure of frisco with Compassion and pragmatism
In 1944 frisco Was Named most Reasonable City By The Tuesday Tuesday evening post
That's Nice That's Real Nice well That's a look your Mayor
You Still Need to call me boss or Kind of I'm Sorry i guess right after
you Got Settled in gary Climbed to the top of the tallest building in frisco and shot Spores Every Whichaway
rose They Say is descendants Still Roam west to the snow
That's a Lot of Gary's That's a Lot of Gary's
Gross Gross Thanks to your assistance Hobart Bumper Got the
Photography Bug or Should We Say The photography owl Anyway he opened an Art Gallery so the
Citizens of Frisco Would Never Have to suffer from the inability to see pictures of Analysis Whenever They Wanted oh?
No
We know i'm not done you said it Wouldn't change anything about the world old
Kurtz Left The fort to set Up shop in frisco his column Fitness Group
Skyrocketed in Popularity
The Gross Was entirely due to word-Of-mouth Because the first rule of kurtz fit is that you cannot Stop talking about kurtz fett
Kurtz Till it Hurts
for Everybody no you Said it Wouldn't Change anything
Wasc oh and the other musician started a Folk Band Which he insisted on calling Wasco & Sons They had one song That People Really?
Liked in a Lot of Other Thongs of People more or less Tolerated
Great For them What a GyP what a bop
What a bop but It looks Like There's more Members of the band that could Be There
Crap You Solved five of Redwoods problems with The increase in morale and Civic Resources They were Able to clear The Weeds from the Road
And Fix the well in Broken Hitch post there was even enough Left Over to give The Mayor's office a New coat of Paint and
Freshmen Refreshed The facade on the buttery biscuit oh?
Ain't That Lovely i wish i to solve more problems i you told me you'd all Be Dead there would be about the
U14 of The reenactment Scenarios at fort Memoriam They still Talk about you
Remember When Mountain that Muffler fella came Through Here yeah he was really good at This game
you Have Any more Repair
All Right
With Your Help Roy beans
Jellybeans Museum became The talk of The town well first i have to build a Town Nearby but once They did
My Beans Jelly oh That Guy's whoo-Whee inge right by the door there i'll look at that whoo-whee?
You Left dirt Water a Nicer Town Than you found it the streets were a Little Safer and the People a Little wealthier and the
Children Liked Ice Cream Just a Little more The Ice cream Thing might not have Been because of you i guess oh?
look At These Happy People
Such Happy People
As for you after your adventure you Settled in frisco and Bought a Very long Very Narrow
House You fill It with Souvenirs of Your Exploits and starting an Antique Hatrack Collection
When you Left home you told Rufus you wanted to help People over the course of your adventure you Helped 40 People
you Weren't Whistling dixie When you declared Your intentions
If You'd Been catholic They definitely Would Have Sanded You if you had Asked but you Wouldn't have Asked Because you wouldn't want to be
Any Trouble Oh, i'm so dies. Oh i'm so fricking Nice
look At Bay in my long Narrow house
Ah, ah!
Look at me but i could have done more look at all Those hats i didn't get. Oh?
Look About My Spittoon and My infinite Bones Where ever i would Have needed that but i didn't Get everything
in 1906 all the remaining cows in the west were
Simultaneously activated By Some Kind of Signal from Hell They Thundered east Forming gigantic single-Minded Herd Led By the infernal Sadist duke bo Victus the
Cow Army Thundered East Towards Bear Water
The Freak
Fortunately a gang a Rodeo Clown Swept in at The last minute and Slaughtered The Herd Just four Reach dirt Water Unfortunately all The town's
Folk and dirt Water had a Hard time sleeping for Pretty Much The rest of Their Lives Seriously It Was a Grisly Sight
420 Years Later Deep Beneath Your
Ground ancient machine Suddenly Stopped Doing The Thing They were built to do it's probably fine you and Everybody know you know are dead By
Then and most of Humanity has Moved to space so though it'S a shame about the planet there were some cool Bars there oh?
No, but i didn't finish the vibrate oh i feel so bad no you said it Wouldn't Change anything. Oh?
Is that It Wouldn't Change anything
Oh, no, oh you said it Wouldn't change anything You said it Wouldn't change anything You said you said oh it feels
Too late now oh he feels too late
It feels too late ah
Too late now oh?
I
Get It anymore
you might Also Enjoy our free browser-based game The kingdom of Loathing on the internet kingdom of Loathing calm ah
I want to play that now ah
Does This Cutscene Change When you do different if you iF i were to finish everything Now would it change
okay
Frick That Feels Very Final oh
Man The Adventure never Ends huh what Am i doing oh?
The Adventure never Ends but Alas i
Suppose it's Ended for Now but that Doesn't Mean it's over Because When i went to packs ii
West i met the developer and he gave me a code for the horse dlc and
This Game is absolutely Amazing and There's more Laughs to be had but i will put it to rest
for Now and
It will come back once i get all This other stuff
in order
Who am i kiddin There's gonna Be another episode in like Two Days but i want me to call This One the ending Because it
Felt Like The ending the ending quote question Mark Maybe
but it's good so thank you everybody so much for watching This game an
Absolute delight If You want to see me play Kingdom of Loathing as well after i get done with all the Extra stuff in this
Game Because i'm gonna squeeze every little Bit of Funny out of This
Because
Like This game Is a delight and a Charm and Was fun the entire Way through i never had a Boring moment in this entire
Game Even Farming Wasn't That Bad and i didn't. Have to farm that Much This game Is a
Goddamn Delight
So thank you to everybody Who's watching thank you to the developer and
Remember
Support The developer There's a Lot of different Ways to play This game You could Play It Evil or you could Go Black hat you
Could Go Hard mode You could be a Bean slinger You could do a ton of different Things
So get the game support the developer i want to see more stuff like This
If any game Needs to be made it's more this so thanks Again Everybody for watching and as Always i will see you
In the next video?